we're asked to plot the image of point a
under a dilation about point p with a
scale factor of three
so what they're saying when they say
under a dilation they're saying
stretching it or scaling it up or down
around the point p
that's what we're going to do is just
think about well how far is point a
and then we want to
dilate it with a scale factor of 3. so
however far
a is from point p it's going to be three
times further under the dilation three
times further in the same direction so
how do we think about that
well one way to think about it is to go
from p to a you have to go one down and
two to the left so minus one and minus
two
and so if you dilate it with a factor of
three then you're gonna wanna go three
times as far down so minus three
minus three and three times as far to
the left so you'll go minus 6.
so 1 or that's let me do this so
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 negative 5 negative 6. so you
will end up
right over there and you can even see it
that this is indeed three times as far
from p in the same direction and so we
could call the image of point a maybe we
call that a prime and so there you have
it it has been dilated with a scale
factor of three
and so you might be saying wait i'm used
to
dilation being stretching or scaling how
have i stretched or scaled something
well imagine a bunch of points here that
represents some type of picture and if
you push them all three times further
from point p which you could use your
center of dilation then you would expand
the size of your picture by a scale
factor of 3.
let's do another example with a point
so here we're told plot the image of
point a under a dilation about the
origin with a scale factor of one-third
so first of all we don't even see the
point a here so it's actually below the
fold so let's see there we go that's our
point a we want it to be about the
origin so about the point 0 0 this is
what we want to
the dilation about the origin with a
scale factor of one-third scale
is one-third scale factor i should say
so how do we do this
well here however far a is from the
origin we now want to be in the same
direction but one third as far
so one way to think about it to go from
the origin to a you have to go
six down
and
three to the right
so one third of that would be two down
and one to the right two or two is one
third of six and one is one third of 3
so you will end up right over here that
would be our a prime and so notice you
are one-third as far away from the
origin as we were before because once
again this is point a under a dilation
about the origin with a scale factor of
one-third